we'd been asked into the clinic of the
al hall camp to meet a young woman
17 years old we were told and here
because she'd been shot
we're protecting her identity and we've
changed her name
she asked us to call her mona how are
you
if only we could show you her face it is
one of an innocence that was ripped from
her
when she was just 11.
[Music]
foreign
after isis was defeated she and her
radicalized mother ended up in this
holding camp for isis women and children
she tells us she resisted the extremism
12 days ago men came into the tent where
she and her friends were sleeping
foreign
just outside the clinic the ideology of
the islamic state confronts us
immediately
there are 69 000 people here most of
them women and children
and many of them utterly committed still
to their caliphate
there can't be anywhere else on earth
like al hall
we're taken to the part of the camp
where the foreigners are held
we pass a group with three injured
children
they fell the woman says and broke their
arms
[Music]
a stone is thrown the front line here
is children with slingshots
born into this camp they know nothing
except the islamic state
it is indoctrination
and it is so terribly sad
a black bag is a toy kite for those who
are not yet throwing stones
this is childhood in al hall
the emptiness belies the mood two men
were shot dead here this morning
[Music]
and a bosnian woman who renounced isis
and tried to escape
was beaten with iron bars by other women
how are you the few who do emerge from
their tents
won't talk to us
[Music]
well the authorities tell us that there
are about 2 000
foreign families here that is people who
are not iraqi and not
syrian we were here a couple of years
ago and they were warning then that
a caliphate could be reformed now they
are saying
it's not a matter of when it has
happened
it is the syrian kurds who led the
defeat of isis exactly two years ago
and it's they who've now been left with
this extraordinary challenge
they are implementing they are they have
their police what we call it alhazbah
and it's all from women who are
pouring this extreme mentality into
their children and the young people who
are
who are there and again who i think
if not dealt correctly with they would
create the next generation of
jihadists to the north east another camp
and a different problem
the women here were part of isis but now
appear to have renounced it
[Music]
the mood is a world away from our whole
children
being children
in the last year 295 families have been
transferred from hull to this place
in an attempt to get less extreme women
out
but then they are all marooned here
their countries don't want them back
this woman from russia accepts that
she's done wrong
but don't punish my children she says
next uh a moroccan woman
and the most striking thing half the
population are children
no one's suggesting that the answers
here are easy there are very very
complex issues but from speaking to the
women to the children to the guards and
to the authorities it's clear to me
that doing nothing really is not an
option
our encounter caught the attention of
the authorities here and she's now been
moved
to a safer place mark stone sky news
in northeastern syria